[Music]
people on earth are tiny creatures at
the bottom of an immense ocean
an ocean of air so vast that it dwarfs
the seven seas
nevertheless the supply of fresh air
available to any city is limited
air overburdened with pollution can be
ruined
just as lakes and rivers can be ruined
despite the vastness of the ocean
into which all rivers eventually run
every city in town enjoys days when the
flow of air is fast and turbulent
and the sky seems fresh and newly washed
but there are periods when the air lies
still and stagnant for days on end
windy or calm rain or shine 24 hours a
day
365 days a year our demands on the air
supply continue
the wheels of industry and of 70 million
automobiles continue to
turn the fires and furnaces of millions
of homes factories and schools continue
to burn
and 180 million people must continue to
breathe
free is the air it's no bargain if you
can't use it
in some respects the ebb and flow of
life in an
energy-hungry fuel-consuming american
city is one great oxidation
the burning of fuels to give muscle to
machines
and breathing to give life to people
we make heavy demands on our air the
same supply
needed to operate a steel mill an oil
refinery
a power plant and a host of power
producing machines
is also needed to provide the newborn
infant
with his first breath of air and all the
breaths he will take throughout his
years of life
there is no escaping these facts the
greater our prosperity
and the greater the number of people the
greater our demands on the air
the greater the variety of material
services and products we demand
the greater the burden on the air in the
last decade or two
our science and technology have devised
many new and ingenious ways to exploit
for our benefit
the raw materials of the earth we
sustain a rising standard of living
which is one of the marvels of the world
thousands of new products each year
hundreds of new chemical
compounds and what shall we do with the
byproduct wastes
many of which are unknown chemically and
untested biologically
throw them into the air throw them now
and breathe them later
smell them taste them swallow them later
we have created an environment which
satisfies the basic material needs of
man
better than any other in history but
with each year that passes
we threaten more ominously our natural
environment of air
land and water dump the gunk into the
river
cut down the trees poison the land in
the air
we are faithful users of soaps and
cosmetics
yet we step outside into a daily bath of
airborne dirt
to which we expose our freshly scrubbed
hands and faces
and also the precious membranes of our
eyes
throats and lungs where do all these
obnoxious gases and particulates come
from
from our industries our automobiles
trucks and buses
from the burning of wastes in hotel and
apartment house incinerators
in community dumps and in our own
backyards
here is a city throwing more
contaminants into the air
than the atmosphere can handle stewing
in a brew of gaseous and particulate
pollutants
cooked by the sun for greater toxicity
greater eye irritation
into somebody's lungs i breathe samples
of all the waste produced by the
greatest producer in history
which ones are we breathing today you
name it
anything and everything from the
fragrance of cosmetics and the aroma of
roasting coffee
to the irritating stench of sulfurous
gases
and the sweetly sickening smell of
rotting garbage
you